in the first part of this series we
learned about how San Francisco's
Chinese fought exclusion in this part
will visit the Mississippi Delta where
Chinese community has played an
unexpectedly important role the
Mississippi Delta home of the blues and
list fields of green and a land
cultivated by the hands of slaves but in
between for more than a hundred years
the Delta has also been home to small
but influential Chinese communities it's
been navigating an identity that's both
American and Chinese the corn when they
describe how that when I get that this
is Sally and Gilroy Chow and this is
their 46 year old walk we heard about
these dinner parties they throw to get
together with friends and eat southern
style Chinese food like fried rice with
lots of bacon so we decide to go meet
them and find out how their families
ended up in the Delta this is a store
that I grew up in many many years ago we
lived in the back of the store every
store we bought another house like most
of the Delta Chinese of the time Sally's
parents opened and ran a grocery store
the Chinese originally came here to work
in the cotton fields with the end of
slavery plantation owners could no
longer depend on the free labor of
slaves so they look to the Chinese who
were cheap disposable and politically
voiceless
but with harsh conditions and little pay
working in the fields didn't last long
they soon started opening grocery stores
in small towns up and down the Delta
Yemeni was a phenomenon when I think
about how the Chinese came they just
settled in the Delta from Memphis to
Vicksburg I mean just look at it it
really sailed a particular need because
nobody else wanted to do it
these stores played a uniquely important
role in the segregated self serving the
black community when the white community
wouldn't and this is significant because
I met more than 70% of the population
got their groceries and everyday goods
from a tiny Chinese community Freitas
family store a minsang started out in
the 1930s as two different buildings
across the street from each other one
serving black people the other serving
white people neither black nor white the
Chinese community found themselves in
the middle it was like oh the rori lying
road all that there were the whites and
the blacks in the chale
we all stayed in our line and we will
find until we crossed over the Chinese
grocers depended on the black community
for business and also served them in
very practical ways like when jeans
father's customers couldn't pay for
their groceries right away
he let them use credit people didn't
have that much cash and so he would have
created and they would come in one week
pay a little bit on a bill and take out
more and that was just kind of how they
survived this kind of trust was
essential because of the economic burden
non-whites face regime grew up the
median annual income for whites was just
over $4,000 more than four times the
median income of non-whites
over dinner Sally and Gilroy's friends
had plenty of grocery store memories to
share with me
whoa the worse when you were old enough
to be able to see over the counter many
of us started working in the store it
was just expected of us living and
working alongside our mom and dad was
seven days a week
morning until night I mean even
Christmas done they open 365 days a year
you know there's one thing I didn't even
realize during the exclusion act the
Chinese were not allowed to own property
so they lived in the back of their
stores even when exclusion ended in 1943
many families couldn't afford to buy a
new home we live behind the grocery
store one big room divided into two ins
we didn't know anything else so we
thought it was kind of fun but you know
as we went to school and realized people
had homes we thought was that different
when it came time for Frieda to go to
school it was the first year that the
town she lived in Greenville allowed
Chinese children to go to white public
school far today at all the shiny
children had to attend this one won't go
heil some of these school houses were
built by the Southern Baptist Church
which remained a big part of Delta
Chinese life before we disaster
blessings on those food ferreted even
with their busy lives between the store
and family the Chinese still found time
to get together for celebrations dances
and of course food there was a definite
camaraderie with the kids in the Delta
it could be a birthday party or wedding
where they would have danced we all just
love getting together and the food is
always phenomenal here we are we're all
lonely in the grocery store and there is
absolutely nothing to look forward to
and and so you can imagine that I mean
here here was something a social event
that the Chinese could could really look
forward to for many years the community
thrived in the Delta but over time as
more farm jobs were lost some machines
unemployment increased and so did
poverty and drug use Chinese owned
grocery stores became easy targets my
brothers I mean they had been victims of
two armed robberies within last few
years luckily they have survived we just
don't even wanna today most of the
Chinese grocery stores are closed the
end of the exclusion act brought new
work opportunities and the original
grocers fulfilled their duty of working
every day of the year to send their kids
off to college many of their children
grow up to be pharmacist some served in
the militaries like Sally's
there Audrey and Gilmer worked on
multiple Apollo missions for NASA but
even though they've been here for so
long the Delta trainees are still often
seen as outsiders I had an occasion to
where I was walking into an office
building and some dear little lady said
honey she says are you ornamental and I
didn't quite know how to answer her I
said sometimes it happens to me all the
time you know like how long you been
here
or who taught you English because always
where are we far I mean that's a great
question I think about that myself all
the time are we always foreigners
because of our because of our appearance
because of our appearance we just look
like we just got here I mean we don't
look like American people despite these
interactions for the Chinese community
here the Delta will always be home
Audrey why do you love it as it's so
peaceful you can't I'll turn my cell
phone off and so I'll just bitch and
nobody's calling me it's just solid -
you enjoying God's creation Sally you're
a Jean Frieda and audre k-- these
friends are some of the few Chinese left
in the Mississippi Delta but they remain
a close-knit group gathering over food
to preserve the memory and legacy of
their families the Chinese American
people definitely made a contribution in
the Mississippi Delta they came and they
definitely made a big contribution here
they do
if you liked this episode on the
mississippi chinese check out the next
one on saint gabriel valley where new
immigrants are completely changing the
restaurant scene even chinese people
think they have the best Chinese food in
America